die öbb stets das gruppe sehr fest
wer stirbt
kerstin langenegger war 20 als sie starb
sie hätte eine neue lunge gebraucht doch
der rettende anruf kann nicht
ihre ältere schwester aline langenegger
hat einen film über kerstin gemacht ein
großer appell organe zu spenden
die schweiz hatte europaweit eine der
tiefsten spende raten
jährlich sterben bis zu 100 personen
weil kein passendes organ verfügbar ist
organe spenden für viele ein tabuthema
ein neues leben bekommen wenn das eigene
nicht mehr will
jeder könnte einmal organe brauchen doch
viele befällt großes unbehagen wenn der
spenderausweis ausgefüllt werden soll
angst beim sterben jede würde zu
verlieren
die ethikerin ruth baumann hölzle ist
deshalb kritisch eingestellt mit organs
band wird die integrität von den körper
eigentlich ganz grundsätzlich verletzt
und dass ich ja also der grundlegendste
opfer rechter die hand aufgrund von
manchen wird und der mannschaft das
häuser körper unantastbar ist ein
betreiber entscheidet was damit
passieren
so gilt schweizweit die
zustimmungslösung
man muss aktiv zustimmen wenn man
spenden will
nur tut man das nicht müssen die
angehörigen entscheiden
eine zumutung für jene die in schock und
trauer sind organe entnehmen darf man
sobald der patient hirntot ist in diesem
moment jedoch wird er noch durchblutet
ist waren selbst die gliedmassen können
noch zucken jetzt organe entnehmen
für viele ein schreckensszenario die
ganze hier und dort definition als
solche mit einer seite definition das
ist nur ein naturwissenschaftliches
faktum sondern wieder ein team an ist
die ntt politische sache und es für die
anderen ist nur eine person
eine frage des weltbildes was passiert
wenn wir sterben
auch wenn es eine seele gibt die
weiterlebt der körper bleibt zurück
könnte helfen andere menschen zu retten
ist es da und solidarisch egoistisch
nicht zu spenden
man solle in ruhe sterben doch
organentnahme ist ein wettlauf gegen die
zeit
und wer bekommt dann eine organ jener
der es am meisten braucht jener der die
besten chancen hat könnte gar jemand
profitieren der selber kein organ
hergeben würde schwerwiegende
entscheidung
auch für empfänger carsten langenegger
haderte lang damit sich auf die
empfängerliste setzen zu lassen
wolfgang abgeschlossen war
andere österliche kraft menschen mit
transplantierten organen sind keine
gesunden menschen an ihnen ist eine
ganze industrie interessiert das ganze
system profitiert und darum ist so
wichtig dass wir wieder transplantation
wird turek wird wirklich füreinander
walid und nicht-finanziellen fressen
organe spenden ist eine freiwillige gabe
darf keine moralische pflicht sein
jeder sollte sich aber bewusst
entscheiden vor allem um die angehörigen
zu entlasten